so you don't have to know matt to be a
software engineer but you do have to
know math to do some woodworking
so
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry oh man
it's hot temperature wise it's not that
hot but
it's really humid here in san diego
which when i was growing up here
it wasn't ever this humid but because of
climate change it's now humid in the
summers so
it's very hot from our little kona dog
walk in the neighborhood
but i wanted to take a moment to say
thank you to the sponsor of this video
lessie
so bessie makes these knit sneakers that
are waterproof
and weatherproof mine are a little bit
dirty from our walks but i've been
wearing these on our walks and they've
been great
not to mention my daily walks also
really help with my mental health
especially during quarantine and coven
and stuff so
they're super lightweight they're more
lightweight than other sneakers that
i've had and also even my flip-flops and
they're also super breathable
i also like that they're like they fit
like socks like i don't know i like
shoes like that ever since i had
a pair of sneakers like that uh for
tennis in high school
i really enjoy these kinds of like you
just put your foot in and then it's like
a sock shoe
here's me showing that they're really
waterproof uh i put my phone inside my
shoe
has been through a lot but they were
protected just fine
so because they're a sponsor of this
video if you want 25
off of your own pair of vessies then go
to bessie.com
myuco the link is also in the
description box down below and thank you
bessie so much for sponsoring
anyways it's really hot and i'm really
hungry so i'm gonna go make some food
but here's the boba recipe for you in
three
two one
so
good weekend morning everybody today
we are working on some woodworking
we are working on some wood we are doing
woodworking yeah we're going to build a
workbench because we've got a lot of
projects that we want to work on but not
really a surface to work on right now
because it's all just
random storage stuff right now so we
figured we should probably build
something
that gives us a good surface this is
what we're building today
we got these plans online we got a bunch
of this wood from the home
store the other day uh last weekend
we've just been leaving it here in our
garage that i can dry out and acclimate
got our shop dog kona and
my assistant scott
are we ready to build yeah let's do it
so we ran into an issue in which the
plans
are a little overzealous in their
measuring 66 inches
plus and a half inches is 92 and a half
inches but the boards are only 92
inches so we're missing half an inch but
also 92
and a half inches is not 8 feet because
when they say two by four by eight it's
not actually two by four by eight
it's some silly ridiculous number which
is why
we vote for the metric system
everything's just way more accurate i
don't understand why it has to be so
hard
i don't i don't think in that it would
matter because it's
the cut but i mean there wouldn't be as
much confusion right because we wouldn't
be calling not two by four by eights
two by four by eight measuring is hard
so you don't have to know math to be a
software engineer but you do have to
know math to do some woodworking
that's good
all right
so
down
just made our first joint
scott i'm a natural
well we joined everything that we could
but we don't have wood screws so we
gotta finish the rest tomorrow
it's looking pretty good those legs
aren't attached but
all the building blocks are there we
still have to do the
tops and bottoms but it's like five
o'clock already so we're gonna
call it a day and do it tomorrow but
good progress today
i'm tired and sweaty